foreign
there's very few times on this show that
we're actually going to be fussing at
you we'll be fussing with you
and if we call you stupid or call what
you're doing stupid rather we won't call
you stupid we might call what you did
stupid but it's because we know what
stupid looks like we've done it I've
done it more than even Rachel Rachel
grew up in a household where I'd quit
doing stupid by the time she was born
and came along I had gone broke but I
know what stupid looks like and we have
figured out that personal finance is 80
Behavior it's only 20 percent head
knowledge
and you've got to study
and think about this money stuff through
the lens of behavior modification
it's not a math problem
so how do I modify my behavior well I
have to commit to and uh my friend James
Clear in this Mammoth book that he did
called Atomic habits I have to change my
identity I am no longer a person
who makes stupid but immature impulsive
financial decisions and then looks in
the mirror and wonders why I'm broke
I'm no longer that guy I instead am very
careful and very slow and one of the
things we'll help you do here
occasionally and you don't even know
we're doing it but it were very
intentional about it is we want you to
have a new identity when you get off the
call
and that guy
doesn't think of himself as a broke
person with forty thousand dollars in
student loan debt but when you have no
money and forty thousand dollars in
student loan debt you need to identify
yourself as a broke person because you
are a broke person broke people don't do
some things that people that aren't
broke can do
and there and you quit doing those
things so that you aren't broke people
anymore and so if you are a doctor and
you make 250 000 a year and you owe a
hundred and ten thousand dollars on your
BMW and four hundred fifty thousand
dollars on your medical school student
loan debt you are a broke but doctor
you need to re-identify
and go this is who I am and I want to
change that identity because then you
quit doing rich people stuff while
you're broke because when you do broke
God so you just have to stop you have to
stop and uh you know it that's when I
went bankrupt and lost everything
because of my stupidity I had to reset
and go guess what
the stuff you believed about money
borrowing all you can getting your
credit card points doing anything you
want to do because I make good money
and everybody's got a different
different definition about what good
money is right I had to re-identify and
go no you're stupid you need to stop
being stupid and I think what's hard is
we've lived in a world in a culture
where you know because of the Avenue of
debt you accumulate not just stuff and
but even if you have a good income like
you're saying the doctor whoever I'm
making good money I have the stuff and
it's like the part of the debts of the
uh what I own minus what I owe doesn't
come as the equation it's just you stay
at that top you know sphere emotionally
instead of looking at the reality of the
numbers so how do you modify Behavior
you first identify reality yeah of where
I am and I'm going to reset my identity
and I don't want to be that person
anymore yeah so I'm going to quit being
that you know I'm gonna do the things
I'm gonna take the steps I'm going to
make the sacrifices so that I don't do
that and I've used the example on this
on the air many times here uh and to the
point that the people in the booth are
sick of it but during covid we were
working the leadership team trying to
keep this place open and I figured out
later that how I deal with high stress
scenarios is I eat
a lot
I ate every donut in a 50 mile radius I
brought Donuts I was already overweight
and when I get to covet I went into
donut mode and I got so freaking fat it
was ridiculous I looked in the mirror
this round head looked like a basketball
it was crazy and I'm like this has got
it you know you're you're a donut eating
fat boy you need to stop this
and that's how you stop it you know you
look at it and you go this is the
reality you have to stop doing this or
you're gonna explode
like the kid on Willy Wonka I mean it's
just awful you know you have to stop it
you have to stop it and so you know no
more donuts and the other day we had the
grandkid birthday with the donuts and
papa Dave made up made a big deal about
he was going to steal one of the kids
Donuts but he didn't touch a donut do it
no more Donuts
I'm completely cold turkey on the
freaking donuts and uh you know I
dropped 40 42 pounds because I needed to
hello you know I mean and that's the
thing everybody has something like that
it's a behavior change it wasn't that I
intellectually and analyzed caloric
intake good Lord no I had to stop it
you know and that this is what we all
have to do I'm no different than anybody
else and that is my point and so guys
this is how money works
it's not a math problem it's a you
problem yep and when you get that man
you got the Ramsay thing down and then
you're gonna go in and this is how we've
talked and controlled and motivated and
list and praised and lifted more people
through their debt Journeys into
millionaire status than any other entity
on the planet
the Ramsey Solutions grew past
millions of people have completely
changed their lives financially because
of us on the radio doing what we're
doing right now us on the podcast doing
us on a stage
right now just telling you how to go be
a hero you're the solution go be the
hero it's up to you yes and so to the
caller earlier
it's up to him like right like if you
continue to just be that in and out
scenario like you're saying that's
that's the result you're gonna get but
you decide that you have to make those
choices it's up to you and if you choose
hey I'm actually gonna go scorched Earth
I'm done because the reality is I am
broke I can't go do these fun things
that I want to do I don't have the money
you're making that choice to later then
actually have the money yes to do
anything you want yes you live like no
one else so that later you can live and
give like no one else you'll never be in
a position again that you have to choose
between your groceries and the broke
single mom in front of you whose third
credit card was denied and you want to
buy her groceries but you can't because
you can't even barely buy yours
and you don't ever want to be like that
again you always want to be the guy the
gal in line behind it goes hey I got
that and this why because I paid a price
I gave up the resort 40th birthday party
and I paid a price
to do the thing so that I can do
anything then and that's how this works
there's not a there's not a middle
ground well I sort of kind of it doesn't
work you're either going to be sloppy
and disorganized and in this country you
can have a really good life with a fair
amount of stress and be deeply in debt
and have a your standard of living is
ridiculous and you make 120 000 a year
you're broke but you have an incredible
life you travel you can buy cars you can
do a lot of stuff that on the surface
looks like you've got it all going on
and you can live a stinking life of rich
people in any other country for sure and
be broke as broke and make it all the
way through to retirement and go gosh I
hope the government which is well known
for its ability to handle money will
take care of me
and and or you can decide I'm going to
be autonomous
and I don't really care what you think
about what I drive I don't really care
what you think about my vacation I don't
really care what you think about
anything I'm as for me and my house
we're going to get our crap together you
can make that decision and when you do
it changes everything it changes
everything not just financially though
as I'm like the underneath the surface
you guys when you live the first example
of that I'm like that is full of stress
and anxiety and pain and tension there's
so much just like you can't even breathe
yeah you got everything but you're
barely hanging on by a string one thing
that goes wrong the entire house Falls
versus the ladder and saying you know
what I'm actually going to build a life
yes all based on me and not all the
other facts you know the other industry
standards it's Botox Financial it's fake
you know it's fake it's a facade it's
more like filler Financial Botox just
plastic surgery Financial whatever right
it's like going to Universal and they
got this beautiful house only when you
walk through the back door there's
nothing there it's just a facade for the
camera and people live their lives that
way